Actually,
and this goes back to,
you know, questions I ask people in interviews,
the ability to think critically
is a skill that translates
to every single job,
so I always look at that.
If somebody doesn't have the specific skill set
that I need for a particular job
but has demonstrated an ability
to think around difficult problems,
to route around things,
connect people,
that, you can train people on individual skills,
it's that real foundation,
the ability to communicate with people,
analyze problems,
those are critical things.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.